The final thing I'd like to ask you to do in this homework is
create a URL that flushes your cache and that should behave something like this.
Okay! So I'm looking at the blog and if you scroll down to the bottom,
you can see there's some age of the query.
And if I already go to /flush
and we can see when we reload this front page, it is 0 seconds old.
Now I made my /flush delete the cache and then redirect to the blog page
I think that's probably the simplest way to do it,
although we won't be checking the redirect itself.
We'll just run it and then reload your pages and see what the query time is.
And If I've to go to any of these permanent links that I just clicked on,
we can see that they all reset to 0 seconds ago as well.
So, when you've got that working, submit the URL to the flush URL here.
And thanks and good luck!